안녕하세요, Variational Quantum Eigensolver 강좌 시리즈에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요.
저는 Victoria Lipinska예요. 이 영상에서는 주어진 VQE 문제를
양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 방식으로 표현하는 방법을 알아볼 거예요.
일반적으로 양자 화학 문제는 시스템의
에너지로 표현돼요.
이 에너지를 기술하는 연산자를 Hamiltonian이라고 해요.
먼저 이걸 양자화해야 해요.
즉, 양자 화학의 언어로 표현하는 건데,
이걸 공식적으로는 이차 양자화라고 불러요.
Hamiltonian이 페르미온 상호작용을 기술한다면, 예를 들어
스핀 오비탈 내 전자의 에너지라면, 이걸
페르미온 Hamiltonian이라고 부르고, 오늘의 출발점이 될 거예요.
그런데 qubit은 자기만의 언어가 있어요.
qubit 세계의 연산자는 Pauli 연산자로 기술돼요.
그래서 여기서의 목표는 페르미온 연산자를
qubit 연산자로 표현하는 거예요.
페르미온과 qubit 사이에는 단순한 일대일 대응이 있어요,
0과 1 상태 사이에서요.
그래서 상태 간의 매핑도 간단해요.
하지만 연산자의 매핑은 조금 더 복잡해요.
페르미온 Hamiltonian은 생성 연산자와
소멸 연산자로 표현되거든요.
그래서 우리 목표는 양자 컴퓨터가 Hamiltonian을
더 쉽게 이해할 수 있도록 만드는 거예요.
수학적 도구를 사용해서 페르미온 Hamiltonian을
gate가 있는 qubit Hamiltonian으로 매핑할 거예요.
다시 말해, 양자 화학 언어와
양자 컴퓨팅 언어 사이를 번역하는 거예요.
두 개의 체인을 상상해봐요, 하나는 페르미온으로 이루어진,
즉 양자 화학 언어의 체인이에요.
다른 하나는 qubit으로 이루어진, 양자 컴퓨팅 언어의 체인이에요.
언뜻 보면 매핑이 간단해 보이죠, 그렇죠?
두 경우 모두 두 가지 레벨을 가진 시스템이니까요.
페르미온의 경우, 상태에 페르미온이 하나 있거나
전혀 없는 거예요.
qubit의 경우, 상태 0이거나 상태 1이에요.
하지만 그보다 더 미묘한 점이 있어요.
qubit 체인과 페르미온 체인의 차이는
물리학에서 매우 근본적인 것, 바로 교환 대칭이라는 거예요.
두 페르미온은 절대 같은 상태를 점유할 수 없어요.
하지만 qubit 체인의 경우는 완전히 달라요.
두 qubit은 모두 같은 상태에 있을 수 있어요,
qubit은 페르미온이 아니니까요.
이제 두 체인 사이를 번역하는 방법을 찾아야 해요.
이미 1928년에, 두 연구자 Jordan과 Wigner가
전체 체인에 대한 페르미온 연산자가
qubit 연산자로 정확하게 표현될 수 있음을 보였어요.
이건 양자 컴퓨터에 가장 직관적인 매핑이에요.
예를 들어, 오비탈의 점유 상태를
하나의 qubit의 스핀으로 매핑할 수 있어요.
실제로 Hamiltonian에 이 매핑을 적용하면 Pauli 연산자의 가중 합이 나와요.
이건 매우 중요한 사실이니까 꼭 기억해둬요.
다음 모듈에서 다시 다룰 건데,
variational circuit이 양자 컴퓨터에서 어떻게 실행되는지 얘기할 거예요.
위의 매핑이 의미하는 건, 예를 들어
페르미온 연산자가 14개라면, 문제를 14개의 qubit에 매핑한다는 거예요.
다행히 qubit 수를 줄이는 영리한 방법들이 있어서
더 적은 양자 리소스로 양자 컴퓨터에서 더 나은 성능을 얻을 수 있어요.
일반적으로 분자 시스템에서는
Hamiltonian의 물리적 대칭성을 알 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 전자의 총 개수는 고정되어 있죠.
이 정보를 활용해서 관련 정보를 잃지 않고
문제의 크기를 줄일 수 있어요.
이 기법을 활성 공간 축소라고 불러요.
이를 통해 qubit 수, 즉 리소스 수를 줄일 수 있어요,
Jordan-Wigner 변환 같은 qubit 매핑 전에요.
이 단계에서는 유효 Hamiltonian을 계산해서
결과적으로 더 적은 qubit을 쓸 수 있게 해줘요.
14개의 오비탈이 있는 예시에서는,
이 기법으로 qubit 수가 단 여섯 개로 줄어요.
이 축소를 더 진행할 수도 있어요.
다른 매핑 방법을 쓸 수도 있는데,
Jordan-Wigner보다 조금 더 정교한 방법이에요.
가장 흔한 예시가 패리티 매핑이에요.
패리티 매핑은 오비탈의 점유 상태를 qubit에 매핑하는 게 아니라,
오비탈의 패리티를 단일 qubit에 매핑해요.
여기서 수학적 세부사항은 다루지 않을 거예요,
하지만 중요한 건 이 매핑에 추가적인
중복성이 포함되어 있어서 qubit 두 개를 더 제거하는 데 활용할 수 있다는 거예요.
따라서 14개의 오비탈 예시에서, 14개의 qubit에서
활성 공간 축소로 6개의 qubit이 되고, 그 다음에 4개의 qubit이 돼요
패리티 매핑의 two qubit reduction으로요.
한 가지 변환을 더 간략히 언급해볼게요.
페르미온 표현과
qubit 표현 사이에서 또 흔히 쓰이는 매핑은 Bravyi-Kitaev 변환이에요.
Bravyi-Kitaev 변환은 qubit을 사용해서 정보를 인코딩해요,
점유 수와 양자 상태의 패리티 모두에 대해서요.
Bravyi-Kitaev 변환은 점유 수와 패리티 정보를 결합하는데,
크기 N의 분자 오비탈 기저에 대해
N개의 qubit이 사용돼요.
하지만 각 qubit에 저장되는 정보는
어떤 qubit이냐에 따라 달라져요.
즉, qubit의 인덱스가 짝수일 때는
해당 오비탈 번호의 점유 수를 저장하는데,
Jordan-Wigner 매핑에서와 마찬가지예요.
qubit 인덱스가 홀수일 때는, 그 qubit은 특정 점유 수 집합의
패리티를 저장해요. Bravyi-Kitaev 변환은 qubit 수가
2의 거듭제곱에 가까울 때 가장 효율적이에요.
Bravyi-Kitaev 매핑은 Jordan-Wigner의 장점과
패리티 변환의 장점을 결합해요.
각 Hamiltonian 항이 작용하는 qubit 수를 줄여줘요.
Hamiltonian에서 많은 수의 qubit에
작용하는 항들은
시뮬레이션에 더 긴 circuit이 필요하기 때문에 양자 시뮬레이션에 중요해요.
이는 Bravyi-Kitaev 변환으로
circuit 깊이가 줄어든다는 걸 의미하고, 일반적으로
하드웨어에서 더 나은 결과를 얻을 수 있어요.
이건 Jordan-Wigner 변환보다 개선된 것인데,
Jordan-Wigner는 N 차수의 qubit Hamiltonian을 만들어내거든요.
자, 이 영상에서는 페르미온 Hamiltonian을
qubit Hamiltonian으로 매핑하는 방법들을 살펴봤어요.
다음 영상에서는 최적의 상태를 선택하는 방법과
variational form, 즉 circuit에 대해 알아볼 거예요.
그때 또 만나요.